das wichtigste an diesem
donnerstagmorgen hier ist der faz früh
denker heute ist der siebte april
schönen guten morgen unsere themen heute
die vertuschung von tausenden toten in
mariupol die abstimmung über die
impfpflicht im bundestag habe ex energie
oster paket und schlag gegen rechten
terror in deutschland vorher noch die
meldungen dieser nacht
amnesty international wirft privaten
sicherheitsfirmen im wm gastgeberland
katar ab die ausbeutung von
arbeitsmigranten vor manche von ihnen
mussten bis zu 84 wochenstunden arbeiten
mit wissen der katarischen regierung so
amnesty
die lebensmittelkrise als folge des
ukraine kriegs wird nach einschätzung
der welthungerhilfe zu neuen
flüchtlingsbewegungen aus ärmeren
ländern führen und dem fc bayern droht
das viertelfinal aus in der champions
league das hinspiel gegen villarreal aus
spanien hat bayern 0 zu 1 verloren
die texte heute kommen von philip
eppelsheim
mein name ist jan malte andresen schön
dass sie mit uns in diesem tag starten
hinter dem panzer rollt das mobile
krematorium es geht kaum grauenhafter
als dieses bild seit anfang märz
beschießen und bombardieren russische
truppen mario pohl ohne rücksicht auf
verluste sagte ein deutsche
brigadegeneral
der bürgermeister der umkämpften
ukrainischen hafenstadt hat russland
vorgeworfen
zur vertuschung von kriegsverbrechen
leichen in mobilen krematorien zu
verbrennen das russische militär habe
die hafenstadt in todeslager verwandelt
das ist ein neues auschwitz wurde der
bürgermeister von mario pohl in einer
mitteilung auf telegramm zitiert die
welt müsse die putin schon menschen
bestrafen überprüfen kann man meldungen
dass mario pohl seit wochen nicht die
geflüchtete stadtverwaltung hatte
vergangene woche die zahl der getöteten
zivilisten in der umkämpften stadt auf
etwa 5000 geschätzt derzeit gehe sie
angesichts der zerstörungen von
zehntausenden toten aus vor beginn des
russischen angriffskrieges lebten in
mariupol rund 440.000 einwohner ungefähr
130 tausend menschen sollen noch
eingeschlossen seien michael matz
brigade general und kommandeur der
infanterieschule der bundeswehr in
hammelburg sagt die russischen truppen
beschießen und bombardieren
besinnungslos wohnviertel ohne rücksicht
auf verluste die flucht aus mario pohl
gelang gestern nach angaben des
internationalen komitees vom roten kreuz
mehr als 500 menschen ein ikk team habe
einen konvoi aus bussen und privatautos
in die süd ukrainische stadt zabrze
geleitet nachdem die zivilisten auf
eigene faust aus mario pohl geflohen
sein die ukraine macht die russischen
streitkräfte dafür verantwortlich dass
mehrfach bus konvois für größere
evakuierungen nicht nach mario pohl
durchkamen
die usa haben neue strafmaßnahmen gegen
russland verhängt und auch die beiden
töchter von präsident putin auf die
sanktionsliste gesetzt darauf außerdem
zwei große russische banken sowie die
ehefrau und die tochter des russischen
außenministers sergej lawrow
die außenminister der nato staaten
beraten heute über eine weitere
unterstützung der ukraine
denn so
nato-generalsekretärs deuten
wir sehen keine hinweise dass präsident
putin es aufgegeben hat die ganze
ukraine zu beherrschen wir müssen die
ukraine unterstützen unsere sanktionen
schärfen und unsere
verteidigungsfähigkeit stärken denn das
kann lange dauern und darauf müssen wir
vorbereitet sein
[Musik]
in deutschland wollen sich bund und
länder heute in sachen flüchtlings
kosten einigen mehr als 300.000 menschen
aus der ukraine wurden bis anfang der
woche hierzulande offiziell gezählt und
im bundestag sagt olaf scholz gestern
hunderttausende kriegsflüchtlinge aus
der ukraine sind in den letzten wochen
nach deutschland gekommen und es werden
mehr werden
sie sind hier willkommen das will ich an
dieser stelle noch einmal sagen
diskutiert wurde über die impfpflicht
lang genug heute wird im bundestag
darüber entschieden befürworter können
sich einer mehrheit bei dieser
abstimmung allerdings nicht sicher sein
die unionsfraktion hat die bemühungen
aus reihen der ampel koalition noch
stimmen von unionsabgeordneten für die
impfpflicht zu bekommen zurückgewiesen
der vorsitzende friedrich merz
kritisierte die zitat verkorksten
kompromisse die die koalition machen
muss weil sie untereinander nicht einig
ist zitat ende der vorschlag mit den
meisten unterstützern zu den weite teile
der ampel koalition gehören sieht ja
eine impfpflicht ab 60 jahren vor
unterdessen hagelt es kritik an
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach und
seiner kehrtwende in sachen corona
isolation
die er offiziell noch mal so begründet
hat die isolationsschicht nach borna
infektion zu beenden war ein fehler oder
wäre ein fehler geworden wenn wir es
geschlossen hätten weil damit der völlig
falsche eindruck entstanden wäre die
pandemie sei entweder beendet oder das
virus deutlich harmloser geworden hat in
der vergangenheit angenommen wurde
bayerns gesundheitsminister klaus
holetschek csu hielt lauterbach jetzt
schlechte kommunikation vor schleswig
holsteins gesundheitsminister heiner
garg von der fdp warf lauterbach ein
ebenso chaotisches wie unprofessionelles
hin und her vor
dass energie oster paket ist geschnürt
in berlin hat robert habeck ein
gesetzespaket zum ausbau erneuerbarer
energien vorgestellt es soll energie und
sicherheitspolitische ziele vereinen es
geht laut habe darum sich zunächst von
russischen fossilen energieimporten
unabhängig zu machen und dann von
fossilen trägern generell kombiniert mit
den anderen maßnahmen die wir ergreifen
glauben wir dass für einen wichtigen
schritt heute gehen die klimaschutzziele
aber auch die energie- und
sicherheitspolitischen ziele die
deutschland sicherzustellen hat zu
erreichten ziel ist dass in acht jahren
mindestens 80 prozent des stroms aus
erneuerbaren quellen stammen sollen
mindestens doppelt so viel wie heute bis
2035 werden fast 100 prozent angestrebt
zehn jahre später möchte deutschland
kohlendioxid neutral sein jedes jahr
sollen windkraftanlagen mit einer
leistung von 10 gigawatt entstehen
zweifel an dem paket gibt es bei der fdp
sie stimmte dem kabinettsbeschluss nur
unter dem vorbehalt zu dass die
liberalen zweifel im parlamentarischen
verfahren beseitigt würden die fdp hat
unter anderem bedenken was den ausbau
pfad des ökostroms nach 2030 angeht
fdp-fraktionschef christian dürr wünscht
sich realistischere ausbauziele bis 2045
es war ein schlag gegen
rechtsextremistische terroristische
vereinigungen mehr als 1000
polizeikräfte haben in elf bundesländern
räumlichkeiten mutmaßlicher
rechtsextremisten durchsucht damit war
es der bisher größte einsatz dieser art
die bundesanwaltschaft ermittelt unter
anderem wegen mitgliedschaft in der
vereinigung combat 18 die seit zwei
jahren verboten ist außerdem geht es um
die rechtsextremistische kampfsport
gruppe knockout 51
bundesinnenministerium faeser sprach von
einem harten schlag gegen die
rechtsextremistische und
rechtsterroristische szene ermittelt
wird gegen insgesamt 50 beschuldigte
vier männer wurden festgenommen
bei ihm soll es sich um den anführer von
lookout 51 sowie weitere
führungsmitglieder handeln kann sich das
thüringer verfassungsschutz präsidenten
kramer könnte es verbindungen zwischen
combat 18 und dem nsu also der
rechtsextremen terrorzelle
nationalsozialistischer untergrund geben
es gebe bundesweite und internationale
kontakte und eine affinität zu waffen
und sprengstoff
das wird heute ein jahrhundertspiel im
viertelfinale der europa league um 21
uhr treffen eintracht frankfurt und der
fc barcelona aufeinander
mehr als 300.000 menschen wollten das
gerne live sehen
48.500 haben es in die seit wochen
ausverkaufte arena geschafft bei der
eintracht ist die rede von der
bedeutendsten partie seit dem
landesmeister finale 1960 gegen real
madrid auch wenn die frankfurter wissen
dass die spanier der große favorit sind
dann nehmen uns noch eben zeit für ein
paar empfehlungen da ist der podcast für
deutschlands der in der aktuellen
ausgabe fragt ob musik aus russland böse
sein kann also ich glaube das ist nicht
richtig diese musik zu boykottieren weil
schikowski selbst oder spanier doch ob
man diese musik russland heutzutage und
mit
assoziieren verknüpfen darf sagt andré
den die zinco russische pianist der
sturz von netrebko und co thema also im
podcast für deutschland online auf
faz.net lesen sie zum beispiel in der
politik die frage liefern wir genug
waffen an die ukraine und in der
gesellschaft geht es um den juwelen
diebstahl im grünen gewölbe und um
erstaunliche sicherheitslücken deswegen
die frage haben die wachleute bewusst
weggeschaut
hauptsache sie hören nicht weg morgen
früh wieder im nächsten faz früh denker
bis dahin einen schönen donnerstag für
sie
[Musik]